the fact that people have been by and
large coming together keeping their
spirits up worldwide that's not how the
movies play out the movies play out that
as soon as this happens the government's
have to come in and crackdown to go in
door-to-door rounding people up or
whatever blah blah blah and it's been a
while and I am I'm shocked by how much
sure everyone is and I'm glad how much
sure everyone is being and frankly I'm
also shocked and delighted by how much
the politicians are keeping it together
how there's a lot of a right lifts you
know at least calling the US they're
calling Boris they're calling South
Korea president moon they're like a
right what do we need to do what's
working over there what's working here
and there's a very and and they're also
being other than obviously China and as
transparent as possible here's what
we're doing here's the numbers here's
what's working for us here's not what's
working for you and I think that makes
people feel a lot like alright
they're on it
Michael motherfunking malice in the
building how are you my brother
yeah good to be here I've got a governor
so I feel like we need to bridge the gap
between our first episode in this one
because this is like someone watching
season one of Michael and Chris and then
watching season five of Michael and
Chris and there's a whole bunch of
narrative that's gone and now we both
we're living together we own a dog I've
met your parents I'm considering
proposal all that sort of stuff
season fives getting serious man so um I
want to ask you what have you learned
since we've been friends so it's funny
I'm gonna answer that question a second
I just finished reading this book which
is called gumption island which is a
forgotten book it came out 1956 by Felix
Morley he was a pulitzer winner for that
he was the first one to win a Pulitzer
for the Washington Post he was one of
the founders of the non Pelerin Society
he later became a prominent you know
anti-war right winger and the book it
takes place basically the premises
there's this Fitness this community in
Maryland in America they're hit by the
Soviets with the weapon and the thrown
back in time to the dinosaur era and
what's amazing about this book there's
all sorts of action that happens off
screen like you're just mentioning and
I'm reading it I'm like did I miss
something like the Russian character
marries the daughter of the other
prominent character and you only find
this out when they're like well ever
since you guys get married I'm like wait
when they weren't everybody is going to
Ramona yeah they're dating one of the
kids is eaten by a pterodactyl and it's
never mentioned again I'm like well
isn't this a problem when children are
being eaten by anything and oh and then
there's this whole subplot where the
bankers in this community want to have a
coup and basically seize control and
like five pages later it's like well
ever since we had to impeach blah blah
blah I'm like wait they the coup fail
like it's so crazy reading like this so
what have I learned
since we've been friends you are you and
I probably chat on a daily basis this
point I think you're probably the
closest person in my life who I've never
met and I think you know week of my life
from probably different perspectives
that similar wiring different very very
different life experiences but a similar
approach beginning extreme intensity
intellectual curiosity pride yet
self-awareness I think maybe we all fail
in some of those maybe not others so I
think one of the things I have well
you've given me some fitness advice
which has been very useful but I mean
since this we became pals it's this
mates I think they say over there
this whole virus thing you know
obviously hit so that's obviously throw
in a number for all of us you know what
the one thing I've learned I would say
if I put the one thing is that I have a
bigger this is gonna sound pompous and I
don't care I have a bigger audience than
I realized and that there are people who
when I do crap like this it actually
gives them something to do so I better
get off my ass and do it I don't have
the space to be kind of in hermit mode I
couldn't agree more man there's a an
analogy that I use all the time about
the hero and the mythological stories
and it's like it's the unwilling hero
the hero has to go and slay the dragon
not because he wants to but because he
can and because he can he has to it's
like if no one else he's gonna go slay
the dragon and I said this to you I was
a camera where I was we were driving
somewhere I'll add you on skype talking
away and I was like man like you have a
particular coalition of skill like a
Liam Neeson I have a very particular set
of skills and you have a very particular
set of skills and if now isn't a time
for people who can make their audience
feel connected and like they're apart of
something if now isn't the time to do it
during a global pandemic where everyone
can literally can't leave the house and
when when is that time yeah but for me
personally there's two big issues with
that one is and I just had to block
someone on a social media because they
were just rolling their eyes that's I
I'm an I'm an extreme introvert
I do not do well with groups which is
not that you know it which is people
misunderstand what introversion is and
also it's the kind of thing where I
don't want to think it's obnoxious to
think of yourself as these people you've
never met you're having an effect on
their life it's like all right get over
yourself but it's like well the data is
there so they think this because this
isn't how I entertain myself and this
isn't how I get out of my funk
I don't watch podcasts it's not my thing
I get very very rest you know and part
of the reason is I'm a talker right and
part so when I have to sit and listen to
two people talking and the more
interesting the conversation the more I
want to be engaged in that conversation
so inevitably it would become a source
of frustration rather than something for
me it's a very of all the activities
this is the one where I wouldn't want to
be on the bench I don't know if they
have that idiom over there whatever they
have yeah whatever they have in cricket
in the sidelines is an interesting thing
about cricket for you so as I guess kind
of similar to baseball but baseball
inherently speeds up the batting process
because it's after three strikes or a
couple of balls maybe you could have
like some strikes some balls or whatever
10 minutes probably at most the bat is
somebody's either at base or ease back
in the dugout whereas there's guys in
cricket
I've played games where one batsman has
been at the crease as its called out out
on the field for days multiple days that
are batsman's done there and if there's
not a lot of other players getting out
that means that especially if you bat
down the order for further down
you're just sat in a pavilion watching
the game unfold like there is no more
lackadaisical sport on the planet than
cricket you just they're like yeah what
observing it happen one of the most
annoying things about cricket and I do
have something annoying is that in 1990
when Sir Geoffrey Howe was turned on
Thatcher and he stood up in the House of
Commons and he had a speech that took
her down days later
and he was just using a cricket metaphor
to talk about why she's horrible she's
gotta go and it's like it's like going
to the crease only to find out you're
something has broken or something and
everyone in the House of Commons like
holy crap I'm like I don't know what
these words are creat like grease uh you
know so it's just like dude if you're
gonna have this speech which is gonna go
international very historic this is the
Judas speech like at least have it be
University or so I don't think cricket
is played outside of like a former
British Empire colonies right it's not
played like France is it yeah it is
played in France definitely British
colonies I think overtakes like South
Africa Australia New Zealand yeah okay
like I don't think can it even plays it
not sure yeah maybe not I don't think
they do I don't think any culture I'm
not sure if Americans have the patience
for cricket man like we do now [ __ ]
everyone's got the patience for
everything yeah yeah I want to I want to
bring up probably the best story that
I've seen recently which is about Rishi
Rishi a sunic who is the British
Chancellor and this is in the
independent yesterday you're strange
crush on Rishi sunic could actually be a
racist fetish yes so a real Helen do
Helen primroses look Rose pluck Rose
yeah that's what I meant sorry yeah yes
so she you know she was the one who and
her a couple her friends they should say
friends colleagues I'm sorry she wrote
an article for some peer-reviewed
journal just fill the jargon and it was
incoherent and she got it through and
she's really excellent on Twitter and
she's one of the people I resent who
doesn't follow me back but that's okay
and she made the point that the social
justice subculture you start with the
reverse with the conclusion and you
reason your way backwards and that's an
example she use she's talking about
cashiers so if you are kind of don't
talk to the minority cashier you're
racist but if you talk to them too much
you're fetishizing them so that you
can't win and this is an example like so
if you don't like a person as a minority
in power
you're obviously prejudiced but if you
do like him you clearly like them for
the wrong reasons and you just can't win
I don't know where this person is they
haven't crossed the pond but it's the
guy who is for a period was going on TV
it's funny looking up reishi reishi
sunic who the British chance he's a man
who's in charge of our budget at the
moment he's the guy that went on TV and
said we are feisty young 330 billion
pounds we will be paying everybody 80%
of their wages because it is important
for us I said we would get it done and
we will get it done when I meant we will
get like do he killed it let's season
one of the British government was
awesome then in season two they killed
off Rishi and Boris because they've been
in isolation so let's use a choice of
words yeah knock on wood doors with us
yeah I'm just gonna stop you I'm sorry I
just had this tweet I go I wish for the
health of Boris Johnson and Jeremy
Corbyn I know it's stuck here now but if
a world leader goes down people are
really gonna start freaking out and the
consequences there are really really
going to be disproportionate regardless
of whether you think Boris Johnson is
the devil though News starts Andrew
Doyle found a bunch of tweets of people
saying I hope that Boris passes away I
hope that he dies this and the other and
he think that how just how short-sighted
you have to be for that to be the sort
of thing that you decide to go out of
your way to type on a keyboard and press
send
well it's two things let's let's meet or
less I'll I'll do them at their own game
right let's let's be out out soulless if
that happens this is going to get people
to like the Conservatives more because
now they have a martyr some he's gonna
be retroactive Lee regarded as a hero
because we always look at people fondly
when they passed and when they're alive
and so this is not going to get you the
result that you want and again not to
mention the social unrest that will
happen as a consequence so there is this
one of the greatest essays I've ever
read online in fact I could probably
name only five essays that I've read
online that are like super is by Slate
start codex and he had this piece called
I can tolerate anything except the
out-group are you familiar with this no
meditations on mole
by Scott Alexander on Slate star codex
is probably the best thing I've read in
the last two years yeah he's so this
piece is a masterpiece because he went
through social media and he compared
people's reactions to when Thatcher died
to when bin Laden died and he pointed
out that when Thatcher died you know the
song ding-dong-ditch his dad is in the
charts and when bin Laden died there are
plenty of people who were like come on
this is a human being even though he was
evil and this dissonance he points out
is similar I don't think he uses this
analogy to the uncanny valley the idea
that when mannequins or you know
cartoons become a little too lifelike
but a little not lifelike enough that
little spot it's actually very
disturbing as opposed to when they look
exactly like humans or they look like
cartoons and it's like when someone is
close to us but just a little off we are
much more put off with them and are much
more hateful then if someone is
completely you know outside the fold
yeah it's a it's a weird woman the the
way that people have been reacting but
yeah okay let's not use the word
kill off they got rid of them from
season two so I'm hoping on Monday
season three of the British government
restarts and I'm hoping that they bring
them back that if they do like it king
in the north type Game of Thrones II
stuff I'm just really sad that Rebecca
long Bailey didn't get the nod because I
was a huge fan of hers because she's a
real life - talia mcgrath and she was
saying how she she lit for this is her
line that she inequality keeps her up at
night and it's like i mean this is it
would have been fascinating to see
because I feel like Boris Johnson and
her are both kind of caricatures of
people and a certain political stance so
watching that kind of like it would but
it will feel much more like a movie than
adults having adult versus cliche yeah
yeah yeah yeah
the next thing so there's only two
things really that I've got to bring up
but the second one is this David Icke
interview on London real did you have
you seen anything about this if I hadn't
brought it up to you over message would
you have seen anything I and I told you
or I thought it was pronounced London
real
isn't there a city called Real Madrid
which is not a sports team Real Madrid
is the team for
Madrid in yeah yeah London's iesous
London real has something to do with
that like maybe it's the British I'm not
even joking
the British fanbase food yeah Ray Allen
Madrid okay no it's I mean it would
actually probably be more fun if it was
that
but let me they're absolutely right they
are they're British fans of teams from
other countries yes um okay not a lot I
think when you come from the country
where the top-flight of soccer football
is played people they get sucked in but
there will be I'm sure I've got a couple
of friends I know that support some
French teams and a couple that supports
some I think it would tend to be that
you would have a preference when other
foreign teams were playing each other
sure but in domestic games you'll have
your own team as well who's the most
popular foreign team in the UK would you
say that is a good question
you Ventus perhaps athletic or Madrid
Real Madrid by and Munich maybe there's
some football fans just screaming at
their phone they know their iPods at the
moment tell me what it is but I think I
think they would probably be up there
all the European ones I don't think
anyone's gonna be living like LA Galaxy
or something like that I don't think
there's gonna be alright so yeah David
Icke you know David Icke is no okay
David Icke is a British how would you
even conspiracy theorist oh I dunno
sticky and that's because we have
someone who Harold Ickes here he's there
what the little Lister people with lives
in Colorado
like David Nicky
so did I get sure I can I'm not sure
okay I'm sorry
okay thank you so he didn't episode
about three weeks ago on London Royale
with with Brian Rose who I've felt a
little bit off with for quite a while
I'll get into that in a second didn't
episode talking about how coronavirus
you know we don't know what it is what
even is the what is korone of other
people
up top they don't want you to know and
so they did basically was that for three
hours then um at the start of this week
I want to say Monday he brought him back
in so
first things first our company is under
a national lockdown mandated by the
government
brian has brought a sixties year-old man
into his office not only is he brought
him in but Brian's had to go in Brian's
not a spring chicken and videographer
photographer sound desk mixer production
assistant you know all that stuff so
they've gone in during a government
mandated lockdown to record this episode
they record it and I've listened to the
full thing and David Icke says he opens
up and it got taken down off YouTube
I'll go into that in a second but if you
go into Apple podcasts for minutes and
33 seconds he saves the sentence this is
this is David Icke this is the headline
there is no Cove in 19 it doesn't exist
yeah so that's how he opens up right
that's that's the headline of this he
says himself itself self-defined and I'm
then on Tuesday YouTube takes the video
down YouTube deletes it had a live
stream it was very well watched it was
garnering a lot of attention that
obviously and they take it down takes a
little bit time Brian getting in touch
with them and says finally finally
speaks to them and they said we have a
policy at the moment and now any videos
that are saying that kovat 19 is fake or
that it's related to 5g as subject to
this same taking down now the problem is
that because they took it down it's
turned from being a discussion about the
credence behind David Ickes arguments to
now a free speech issue
yeah and it's immediately just they're
trying to censor the truth bro that's
the the first thing that everyone has
now and I don't believe that youtuber
right in taking it down I don't think
that they there was some evidence that
people had set fire to 5g towers in the
UK but it wasn't as if it was incited by
that episode so I don't really think
that they have any reason to do that but
they did and now Brian Rose has been on
an absolute warpath like [ __ ] the BBC
[ __ ] Facebook [ __ ] Instagram I don't
even need
very narcissistic very very
self-involved incredibly self-involved
and that's kind of been one of the
biggest things that's happened in the
internet in the UK this week been pretty
mad well that's you know it's funny he's
so he had the exact opposite reaction
that I had my reaction is no one cares
what you have to say so I can just sit
on my ass and be fine
obviously he's got a much bigger
audience than I do and his reaction goes
everyone cares would have to say and if
I don't do this this is a kind of world
threat to the world this hasn't crossed
over here I am I don't know about this
being a free speech issue what I am
concerned about and I've talked to many
of my friends you know I'm an anarchist
and and very very skeptical of
government power but we are all very
happy that in every country it hasn't
become rioting it hasn't become civil
and arrests that yeah sure these laws
are in place but I think people are more
than happy to do this voluntarily and
I'm shocked and delighted how much
because we've all seen the thing that I
was having a very big issue with this
whole situation was transitioning I'm a
New Yorker I've been here all my life
and you and I talked about this on the
phone how it was very difficult for me
psychologically as a New Yorker to see
the streets being empty it's something I
just couldn't just I felt like I was in
a movie or a crazy person and there were
movies like I'm legend or Vanilla Sky
where you've seen this but deceit in
reality it just was a disconnect and
this had you laughed but this really had
really bad psychological consequences so
I know you're right to laugh but at the
same time I am glad and the fact that
this happens so quickly is also that
there was no real transition it's
overnight like don't get your house will
come out the fact that people have been
by and large coming together keeping
their spirits up worldwide that's not
how the movies play out the movies play
out that as soon as this happens the
government's have to come in and
crackdown to go in door to door rounding
people up or whatever bla bla bla
putting and I know in like South Korea
they're thinking about putting these
bracelets right and so on and so forth
and we haven't gotten there yet but it's
been a while and I and I
I'm shocked by how much sure everyone is
and I'm glad how much sure everyone is
being and frankly I'm also shocked and
delighted by how much the politicians
are keeping it together how there's a
lot of a right let's you know at least
calling the US they're calling Boris
they're calling South Korea president
moon they're like a right what do we
need to do what's working over there
what's working here and there's a very
and they're also being other than
obviously China as transparent as
possible here's what we're doing here's
the numbers here's what's working for us
here's not what's working for you and I
think that makes people feel a lot like
all right they're on it yeah I couldn't
agree more man like the response has
been surprisingly mature from yeah
everyone public and government and of
course it's people online who are
rolling their eyes right now but like
how can you say that given X Y & Z well
yes I'm saying that considering that
information that you also have given
that negative stuff and the positive
stuff I am the fact that we're not in
Lord the fly is the fact that we're not
in that max the fact that we're not in
you know we had rights and in Baltimore
we had rights in st. Louis not that long
ago the fact obviously it's harder to
ride it when there is disease around but
rioting is not a rational like you know
you don't sit at home you're like
alright when would it be most feasible
to riot right it's it's a powder keg
here's another one the fact that we
haven't had home invasions things like
this and people getting god forbid raped
in their homes I mean this is sitting
ducks
that is really gratifying and this is
another reason I am you know I'm a
hardcore optimist and I'm a hardcore
optimist not because it's my nature I'm
Russian born it's my nature is the
opposite I'm a hardcore optimist because
a look at the data and if you're gonna
be a cynic and you looked at the
situation now you'd predict oh people
are gonna be starving blah blah blah
it's like no no people are really
bending over backwards to maintain this
social order now we'll see how long this
lasts but it's lasted quite a bit of
time already and it's mostly expected
the thing that I that is becoming
increasingly challenging for me and I
don't know whether this is just who I'm
exposed to online or some of the stuff
is it's an easy step from that to the
conspiracy theorist types that
believe there's a second motive to
everything that's going on for them to
say while see this just proves how
compliant the public is when the
government decide that they're gonna
shove their hard rod of [ __ ] policy
up your there eroding your rights
they're taking away this they're taking
away that and you're like it dude
[ __ ] give it a rest like what's your
alternative genuinely what is your
alternative to this would you rather
that people were so Brian rose again
like the guy is brazenly walking around
London filming videos 10:30 hey guys
10:30 p.m. London real offices just
finished up here just wanted to give you
an update it's like Brian mate there is
a [ __ ] that's why you sent me that
video there was like now it clear ok
yeah yeah you sent me that video I
didn't it's no no no no I said you I
sent you a video of him by day on the
reactor yeah on the rooftop of
government of London reals offices
saying just finished a workout here
London real HQ done some kettlebells
some Sprint's bit of breakdancing in the
stairwell can you imagine coming down
the stairs to find Brian rose from
London Royale doing breakdancing on the
landing Brian can you stop [ __ ] power
windmilling please I'm trying to get to
the so I mean that's just me you're not
above the law and he keeps on saying and
one of the things he keeps bringing up
is um we have this little thing in
America called the first dick First
Amendment yeah the Constitution I'm like
the elephant in the room Brian is that
you are not in America like yeah you're
in the UK we have hate speech laws over
here for better or for worse most people
would say for worse but countdown killer
all these people that have been you know
criminal records locked up etc etc for
this and this is at the same time so the
Chief Constable of north um Northampton
ship police so that's a real person that
sounds like a title that we would make
up to make fun of you the Chief
Constable of the what northeastern sure
police when your title is a sentence
yeah she's a constable of Northampton
Shire police okay said people are
persistently and consistently
breaking the law by flouting lockdown
and they could get criminal record he's
issued essentially broader scope for his
officers to enforce the law and he
mentions he's like we'll check if we
need to we have the ability to check
what people have in their shopping to
check whether or not they're going out
to buy an xbox controller or they're
going out to buy milk and if you're
buying an Xbox controller we'll find you
that's not where they're at but that's
where he's getting to all the while
Brian rose from London Royale is getting
a senile old man to come and talk about
lizard people in his offices in the
center of one of the most populous
cities on the planet
during the middle of a global pandemic
and I can like it's just really I
already had a Brian was already on my
watch list he was already on my current
list and now he's just like gone
straight to the top I don't know they
have anything particularly to add to
what you just said I mean that I can see
how that would be it I think there's
also probably an emotional sense is this
parted for you that how is it that no
good deed goes unpunished like you're
that you're playing by the rules you're
trying to stay saying you're locked in
your house and this guy gets to do what
you wish you could be doing breakdancing
the stairwell so it's kind of like it's
it's when people who are rules breakers
but in an obnoxious way get rewarded I
think that sets up our sense of justice
yeah I think as well there's something
incredibly insincere about the way again
because you can't frame it up against
his character it's a little bit more
difficult but anyone that's listening
will know no no I mean if they know
Brian real Brian rose and he was taking
selfies on the London Underground a
while ago before mandated lockdown was
in but when suggested isolation was
still going talk it was just him just
him on the London Underground and an
empty carriage essentially being like I
am here look at me I am a thought leader
within this space and he kept on talking
about we need leaders and men of action
I'm like we need people to stay in the
[ __ ] houses Brian you need to go
breakdance in your living room and you
need to just do what every other
podcaster when Joe Rogan is doing
episodes of a Skype with like [ __ ]
Dan Crenshaw and that virologist the
other day and he has been not
the most like voracious advocate for not
doing that he's like I hate doing
episodes over Skype you know when he's
prepared to bend his room yes and he's
the biggest on the planet or what he
does like why why why can't you
especially when you bring in an O ap in
C if if this if this Brian guy was smart
he would make a point which does have
historical beta basis and I just talked
about this earlier on a radio show today
here in the States
1918 was when the u.s. entered the great
war and this was for many of the at the
time progressives a huge thing because
they're like all right we're going to
this war we're going to have our fantasy
that we've been advocating for a couple
of decades now of having the state
manage the entire country basically one
giant company so now we have to do we
have to have complete centralization of
production centralization of Taxation
we're going to have Institute censorship
control the mails things like that so
for them they're like if we're gonna go
into this great war like we're gonna get
a lot of useful data out of it by seeing
how much we can get away with and what
its gonna look like so that when the
Great Depression hit 14 years later or
excuse me 11 years later and then FDR
was elected in 32 inaugurated 33 a lot
of his New Deal programs they were like
all right we went through this during a
war now you're not going to [ __ ] and
moan that we're doing it during the
Great Depression because you've already
been preconditioned it's like the second
time you get into a fight versus the
first time you get in a fight it's gonna
be night and day because you're like all
right I've been through this it sucks so
he does have a point in that if in five
years some government was like we need
to do this totalitarianism a lot of
people would be saying sincerely guys
it's not gonna be that bad we've been
through this before and we've all done
it so stop your complaining so they are
necessarily I don't but the thing is
he's saying intentionally I'm sorry like
sure I'll accept the fact that every
politician and some loves a sociopath
but when you look at how they talk all
everyone I've seen from around the world
they all are freaking out not freaking
out but they're all extremely concerned
they all feel the weight of this on
their shoulder
you'll have families you know they all
have moms and grandparents or whatever
things like that
and they're like all right like the way
how do we get out of this I I don't
think they're thinking long-term this is
our globalists moment to implement the
master plan I think they're faking very
short-term absolutely yeah when the
lizard people's parents and grandparents
are dying just as quickly as everyone
else's you kind of just it's the same
thing as if you fall in a quicksand
right you don't have an existential
crisis when you're falling into a quick
Sun now you just think about getting out
there's this concept by Matthew Siyad
that I have to tell you about right it's
called compensator II control be heard
about this no got why conspiracy
theories and demagogues spread in times
of worry and uncertainties this is
Matthew Siyad piece in The Times oh can
I guess where his answer is yes and
let's see if I'm right okay I are you
saying he's on the level this guy what I
mean I mean are you saying that what
he's saying actually reports the truth
or he's using it as an example so I was
wrong is he going to say that in times
of panic any kind of explanation that's
kind of an Occam's razor that gives
people a sense of certainty is enormous
emotional reassuring you are a very
clever man you are oh yeah that's right
he's absolutely right man let me hit you
with this so yeah psychologists have
conducted experiments to shed light on
why people lose or at least suspend
rationality one experiment asked people
to imagine going to a doctor to hear an
uncertain medical diagnosis such people
were significantly more likely to
express the belief that God was in
control of their lives
another asked participants to imagine a
time of deep uncertainty when they
feared for their jobs or the health of
their children they were far more likely
to see a pattern in meaningless static
or to infer that two random events were
connected this is such a common finding
the psychologists have given it a name
compensator II control when we feel
uncertain when randomness intrudes upon
our lives we respond by reintroducing
order in some other way superstitions
and conspiracy theories speak to this
need it is not easy to accept that
important events are shaped by random
forces they
is why for some it makes more sense to
believe we are threatened by the grand
plans of malign scientists than some
chance mutation in a silly little
microbe yeah and and there's a couple of
examples of this I given talks and
networking and I tell the kids I go if
you're don't aspire to excellence it's
not gonna be possible at your age with
your skillset aspire to competence if
you're confident you're at the 80th
percentile and an example I use is I
would rather you tell me you will have
it on Wednesday and I'll have it on
Wednesday then you tell me you'll have
it on Monday and give it to me on
Tuesday does it make sense if you think
about it but in other sense it does
reassuringly III
there's a therapist I know his wife had
this disease after 9/11 so on and so
forth people would rather like the fight
example right like if you've never been
in a fight what the hell is it once
you've been it sucks but it's in the
Fiat the irrational fear is not there a
disease they found yet people would
rather say you've got leukemia then four
go on for years and they don't know
what's wrong and know where you go yeah
and that's just how we're wired and I
cannot you and we could all understand
if we think about it I'm so like I mean
it's addictive we want to bring all to a
chaos yeah what about like a
relationship like what's going like but
suppose that Facebook thing it said it's
complicated like we'd rather be like are
eggs done a lot of times when when
things are ambiguous like okay I can't
even deal with this I have to break it
up as opposed to I don't know what the
situation is have you heard of the
Zeigarnik effect no what's that okay so
it's a just how the brain has open and
closed loops and it's a writing tool
actually which might be interesting for
you to know considering that you might
start writing again soon and this was
used by oh my god a very famous author
and there's gonna be people shouting it
the the podcast again saying who it is
very famous author back in the day who
would use this essentially the brain
doesn't like open loops and it does like
closed loops however open loops can be
manipulated so for instance let's say
that you do a day of writing and you
finish a session at night you could
finish the sentence one word in rather
than a full stop because then when you
come back to it the next day that loops
open rather than closed so you just
continue and open loop
rather than having to reopen a brand new
one that's on the back end of something
that's being closed off it's the same
reason why we don't like like you say
cliffhanger endings at the end of TV
series they're so compelling we need to
watch the next season of Michael and
Chris because we want to know what
happens next right we need to know
that's that's what gets them Zeigarnik
effect open-loop closed-loop that's
interest III that's actually speaks to
how I write and then we're going to talk
about your shirt cuz I'm very curious I
when I write I do three pages at a
session and then I force myself to stop
so that means I never have writer's
block because I have more in the can
tomorrow and I know I'm not gonna have
to I'm picking up where I left off do
you so do you have a note-taking for
like you might have all of these ideas
right now and kind of figure out do you
just sort of throw them down on a I've
got a separate document or if I have
like a future scene or future section in
the book I'll hit return twice and I'll
write that and then when I go back and
edit I'll put the space in between that
much so that that must be beautiful to
reach a section that you need to write
and find that a past version of yourself
has already written it for you I can
present from past Michael to present
Michael I've been doing a lot of this
time-travel kind of thinking I had this
tweet which I thought was really helpful
which is if you're someone who's dealing
very poorly with isolation we have
suicidal ideation or depression or
anxiety I said write a note to yourself
when you are gonna be freaking out
because this is your rational self
traveling in time to talk to your future
self and you'll know that this person is
telling the truth in writing and I said
and you and I did this I said also make
a promise to someone that if things get
really bad you'll hit them up and you'll
know you made that promise
things are bad I gotta talk to this
person before I do anything crazy and
when we do these notes
another thing is I'm gonna be a little
frivolous is with like maintaining your
if you're on a regimen you're eating a
certain way the reason diets don't work
is if it's it willpower is finite so if
you're constantly having to have what am
I going to eat what I'm going to eat
you're gonna add some point
have a disorder thinking and he start
eating the wrong thing and it becomes a
spiral whereas if you tell yourself this
is what you're eating for this week you
know no matter what you're feeling in
that moment I was in my right mind on
Sunday so I'm going to listen to him now
I'm gonna ask you about Carlo club
because one of the most profound things
I've ever learned was from my friend
Marsha who ran something called cuddle
party here in the states and what cuddle
party was and it was a big joke
although when people thought about for
30 seconds they realized this isn't
really a joke it's actually a great idea
is people who get together and they
cuddled because physical contact is so
important for all of us as human beings
and I asked her well how do you like I
mean doesn't get like orgy like like
what happened she goes yeah yeah she
goes well they have a line like trust
about don't fear the boner and that's
that's kind of funny the other line they
have is she says is it is incumbent in
each of us to establish her own
boundaries because people will take
people take as much space as you let
them and I'm like wow and when she said
that I think I bring this up all the
time it's so important for all of us on
social media to be like no no I'm not
dealing with another moment of your BS
because you can't expect that person to
respect your boundaries now what is
called a club so I'm wearing a t-shirt
which on the front and the back says
cuddle Club and it is by built up north
which is Paul warrior one of my coaches
from CrossFit
it's his clothing brand sports clothing
brand although it crosses somewhere
between Supreme off-white and like a
good sports brand
I guess so this is this is a training
t-shirt this is what I would I would
train in and cuddle Club is a concept
that they've been throwing around for
ages in fact they've just donated I want
to say two-and-a-half grand to mind
which is the one of the UK's mental
health charities from a release a
limited edition release of long sleeved
cuddle club tops same as the one I've
got on it so I bought one of those and
it's a reference to people working hard
in workouts this is not [ __ ] cuddle
Club like ow you don't get
this is this wasn't a cuddle club like
really nice this couldn't be further
away kind of from your ladies what sons
absolutely lovely a lovely experience of
people kind of giving each other support
and love this is more like let go of the
[ __ ] balloon no one's gonna do the
work for you have a t-shirt in there
from the same brand which says the magic
you are looking for is in the hard work
you are avoiding oh yeah yeah so then
sorry what a lot a lot of this stuff so
shout out poor warrior Jordan and Tim
who'll be listening who are all pushing
this sort of rhetoric when it comes to
training I think it's so cool and it
reminds us especially when it gets to
training we can become especially if
you're slightly cerebral and a lot of
CrossFitters are oh yeah rep scheme this
workout hours of sleep I'll track it on
my wit band this is my HIV last night
all this stuff you kind of forget that
there is just a raw animalistic nature
to training where you kind of need to go
balls to the wall and perhaps give risk
forget risk for a little bit and just
focus on intensity and have faith that
your physiology that your training that
your movement engrams your nutrition
everything will kick in at that time so
this is this is not cuddle club but it's
also a funny joke because there's a
bunch of boys that work for us who went
through a period where they just
couldn't have sex they kept on going
back to girls and girls houses after a
night out and they were unsuccessful
rebuffed think in one form or another or
couldn't get it up or whatever it might
have been and then this t-shirt I bought
the t-shirt at the same time so it's
very timely on like a number of levels
well that speaks let's talk about the
flip side of that that speaks to there's
a great British band I could not adore
more I have a framed picture of they're
signed in my living room saint-etienne I
know if you're familiar with them
they're all they're a club band and they
have a song called soft like me and it's
just encouraging people to be soft but I
think a lot of times and I've got
messages to you that we need to be kind
to ourselves and we tend to think that
if we are relaxing or especially when
were younger I have a protege and and he
kind of had this I had to talk about a
bit like whenever I get a paycheck 10%
that money has to be spent on
frivolities I put that a
side because otherwise being
self-employed I remember the lien years
not that I'm particularly wealthy now
and I would always rather wait for the
Train than pay for the cab and now it's
like that tithe like you have to throw
this money down the drain so that if
you're earning money enjoy it so I think
a lot of times we have trouble confusing
am i being kind to myself or am I being
lazy because the mind is very good at
finding excuses not to do the work it's
very good at finding excuses don't go
the gym you go tomorrow play the video
game and that's not what I'm talking
about but it is something it's very
important for driven people to be able
to relax enjoy the fruits of your
Labor's and and instead of beating
yourself up all the time give yourself a
kindness because if you are beating
yourself all the time because you have
this kind of maybe not as good
self-esteem I'm not saying that's your
problem it's not yours problems are our
problem well maybe that person with low
self-esteem could use a little kindness
and maybe that will make his or her life
a little brighter so this is something I
think is under and that's obviously not
really the opposite what they're saying
you shouldn't half-ass your workouts but
this is something I think a lot of us
could use a little bit more of and
there's also something I'm very opposed
to in my work I don't know if it's that
way over there but here in New York and
in media circles there's this really
nasty sneering cynicism towards any kind
of kindness or warmth or friendliness it
seemed as i rolling it seemed as corny
it's and it's like you know you're hard
to give an example well like any kind of
any kind of movie or kind of expressions
of affection you know is really kind of
like oh god oh please it's like it's
like it's it's a regard as ridiculous or
somehow less than music right or movies
if the plot isn't about pathos and about
like you know depravity and it's just
about like a family having a fun
vacation and it's very kind of
heartwarming a lot of times it's not
regarded as legitimate as if they'd gone
through you know the kid having leukemia
and make-a-wish and so on and so forth
and I hate that attitude I really hate
it I think kindness goes a long way and
here's another example social media
I've always always against this idea
that if something is common that doesn't
mean it's the norm just because everyone
does something does not mean it's
actually how things should be and that
is acceptable and it's perfectly
appropriate on social media to go up to
strangers and just call them the
nastiest things possible and it's like
congratulations you found a more honest
on Twitter like this is your big
accomplishment for the day there's
there's no shortage of them whereas it's
I'm a big troll as you know as many as
several issues right now my way that I
stick I've always trying to push
trolling to the next level and my
trolling technique for 2020 I started
out is I've been texting and writing
messages to friends of mine really kind
things being like hey thinking about you
today just one you know I appreciate you
as a person and they don't know how to
react and it freaks them out and that's
just so it's win-win for me hey Michael
are you okay and I saw in the truth my
life is genuinely better since I've met
you and they're like well how do I
respond because we don't have that space
to be kind to one another everyone has
to have a joke or dismiss it and I'm
like that's that's a little insidious
there's so much there's so much for us
to unpack from this but you know people
that are listening here's one thing that
I realized I was doing I was really bad
at taking compliments
really I would brush them off so III had
impostor syndrome so bad that someone
would say something they would go out of
their way
genuinely go out of their way to say hey
man you know des is I really like the
way that you picked your arbitrary thing
that I do open a can of coke right words
do your marketing copy what it might
have been like a physique compliment
back in the day or it might have been
someone to do the business or whatever
it might be and I would I would say
something back like oh yeah well you
know like that's what happens when
you're a total prick all the time or
when you've got no life outside of the
gym or whatever it might be like and it
was for people that are listening think
about how you respond to compliments and
if that's the sort of thing that you
that you say there's a couple of
implications
the first one is that's because you
don't believe that what the other person
is telling you is true that's the reason
you do that and by not
needing to accept it you close the gap
between your self-image and what that
person is saying but the more important
thing and this is what really changed it
for me because I want you to try and
find more of a connection with people
and there's an only child this was like
a weird kind of bridge for me to get
over what I realized was it's really
insulting for someone to go out of their
way and compliment you and feelings of
vulnerability [ __ ] rebuff it they've
said something really really kind and
nice to you and you've just thrown it
back in their face like [ __ ] you like
and that's why a lot of people and this
was me for ages I would say how'd you
know what it is I just don't really feel
that people care about my work or they
don't really like my where I'm like I
wouldn't [ __ ] care about your work
every time someone says something nice
to you you just spit it back in their
face yeah it's it's actually but there's
something else that there at a certain
point people when you're certain
sandi be Asians away from the mean
people don't know how to connect with
you like I have a good buddy now and
he's like into bodybuilding and he's at
that point where you will notice him he
walks in a room and everyone has some
reaction it's never just nothing right
and men are often feel like like I you
know I wrote a book on North Korea I've
been to North Korea and if it comes up
at a party this happens inevitably and
not like what's your book of North Korea
they feel the need to just tell me
everything they know if at North Korea
I'm like this isn't a test and you can't
win and it's fine that you don't know or
care about North Korea this isn't how
but they don't they're trying to build
that bridge between their circumstances
in mind when the bridge is already there
so like when guys come up and they feel
the need to have this conversation and
be all like not complimentary more like
almost like a servile Lee you know like
Oh above law like he's like I don't know
how to react because either I come off
like a douchebag or I come off whatever
I go just tell them you're compensating
for your tiny penis and when you say it
like that the guy will laugh and it's
like oh this guy's normal he just likes
working out well he's like this is a
good a good point to interject here why
don't you mention cuz I haven't heard
you say this and I haven't asked you
this well you tweeted one of the most
complimentary things that I think
anyone's ever tweeted about me
roughest podcast and he said there's
only two people in my life ever that
have two people whose opinion change the
most after I talked to them yeah was you
and Joey salads yeah what did you really
do cuz I want another Joey salads is an
internet he was like a prankster on
YouTube he's a youtube personality
he's a total bro like you know in every
way he came to and he was running for
Congress I think he still is and he came
to do my show and I'm like this guy's
gonna be a total [ __ ] and I'm gonna
completely clown him and within minutes
he was like I don't know about the fed
talking about the taxes I do know about
social media I think the Republicans
need an AOC I think I could bring that
to the republic and I'm like oh so he
wasn't presenting himself as anything
other than what he was he was open about
his limitations and he's like here's how
to get laid like he's like this is what
you got to do an Instagram blah blah
blah and he's giving me tips like from a
friendly place and I was like I had him
completely completely wrong and when
you're coming from that when you have
it's that the expectations game right so
when I came in I thought this guy's
gonna be a joke and right away
he's not that he's being humble it's
that he's being honest he's like I don't
know these things I mean if you're gonna
try to play God share with me about
foreign policy yes you'll win so I was
like oh [ __ ] this guy because a lot of
these youtubers you think that they're
gonna have their head up their own ass
that I'm sure many of them do I haven't
met many it was not that way at all and
ever since then I will always sing Hayes
on your praises it's just like oh it's
really it's it's just interesting how we
come and we have to have these
heuristics when you're travelling in
these circles about okay what box is
this person probably coming out of
because you have your love island thing
it's like alright like I know this
person's like oh no I don't I know what
I think is this person an idea yeah a
good example of youtuber that I think
has really taken the red pill on a lot
is Logan Paul like that guy is operating
for orders of effect down from
everything that it is that he does I
don't know whether you saw do you see
the thing about where he said he was the
fastest
man on the planet who now is so he went
on he went on NBC business do they have
like an NBC business channel or CNBC yes
like so they're talking and this lady is
asking him these questions dude he got
to go back and watch it it's phenomenal
so they're trying to talk to him I think
it must have been just after the tax
year it ended or something and they're
trying to say so Logan you've just been
rated as one of the top earning
youtubers last year you were your
revenue was 14 million and he's going
yeah well Michelle you know I really
think I might be the fastest man on the
planet like I really could be the
fastest man on the planet like you know
I definitely the fastest you but by by
by a country man and he's just going on
and then she's laughing so she's quite
endeared to it and it's a semi
good-looking host lady as well so it's
kind of like you're seeing her try and
battle against his genuine charm and I'm
not like a massive log and Paul fine but
[ __ ] me he and he knew what he was doing
and sure enough the net out he's
trending he's trending on Twitter like
because everyone's going oh my god Logan
Paul what [ __ ] idiot and then Logan
he trolled everyone I maybe thought you
maybe you made me not hate Logan Paul
with just that one anecdote dude he's
he's really operating very very cleverly
and then he I think a couple of days are
a couple of weeks later he tweeted the
back end of his YouTube studio ad
revenue for what he'd seen changing his
channel from doing that and was like
how's this for finance news for you Wow
okay I'm impressed he really blew me
away by that yeah proper proper [ __ ]
good guy I've just remembered you
disagree with one of my videos oh yes
you had this video where you are
advising people that we all desperately
want to be we aren't normal but we want
to be normal right
and I think the vast majority of people
do not have any independent thought
whatsoever and many of them resent the
very idea of independent thought and
individuality yeah I agree
no okay well the same thing yeah I don't
I don't think that that's wrong I think
what I get worried about enough this is
speaking from personal experience is
individuals that dilute down their own
unique offering that they have the
calculation of oh yeah skills life
experience background odd left field
thought and they choose acceptability
over honesty because they want to be
well-liked and there's that quote from
my friend George McGill who says I'm
astounded by how many people want to be
exceptional in life but also want to be
well-liked and normal by definition
being normal
requires you to regress to the mean
order yeah yeah ordinary people get
ordinary results extraordinary people
get extraordinary results and I think a
lot more people become normies through
the diluting down and the the nursing of
the corners and the edges of what makes
them interesting because they're scared
of not being accepted well that's that's
something that is an existential
nightmare and I think that's something
thankfully that's decreasing because the
more that there's people like Rogan and
all these other types who are
encouraging people to find their own
path and I think now being different in
a genuine way like you know like I I
have this guy who I exchanged things
with he's a metalworker you know he sent
me this worry coin I care around with me
he's you know like people doing cool
awesome things I'm not saying he's a
freak but he's not normal the more of
that there is I think in high school you
know back in the day there would be it's
a lot easier to isolate and marginalize
that person but now with the internet
it's very it's much much much easier for
that person to create an audience and to
have people drawn to him so that
pressure which may historically been the
case cuz you're gonna have to work for a
company is really thankfully a bygone
thing and my audience certainly is very
I'm very very opposed to normalcy and
this idea that we should strive for
normalcy and and so I I think I think
that's very sad I think a lot of things
also
happen is when people are young and
their parents are forcing them you know
like I tell kids I go look you want to
be an author right go to any band you
tell your parents you're gonna be an
author they're gonna yell at you and
blah blah and you can't make a living
and so on and so forth then it's
extremely hard there's no question but I
said go to any bookstore write look
around look at all those shitty shitty
books that could be you
you could be that mediocre author but
when you put in those terms right away
it's like oh this is feasible right so a
lot of times we have this idea that to
be kind of exceptional you have to be
Einstein or you have to be Rembrandt
it's like no no no that shitty authors
also has a weird job and is exceptional
and maybe you're not gonna get even to
that level but I promise you by the time
you're 30 40 if you haven't tried you
will regret it for the rest of your life
and if you tried and failed you still
wouldn't care because you shot for it
and you're like I wrote a book it didn't
get published but you know I learned a
lot from the experience everyone who's a
car and this is such a cliche but people
haven't gotten through their head
there's the seen and the unseen every
single person who's accomplished has an
entire storage case full of failures but
you're not gonna see that because that's
not what reaches the public
consciousness so it's it's like yeah I
promise you I've got three books on my
computer that never got published that's
okay so you need you need to understand
that it's it's not a failure it's just a
learning process and the other thing is
you keep knocking on doors eventually
one's going to open it becomes math it's
not even a question of your talent it's
just a question your stamina yeah
there's a quote from Navarro Vacanti
I've been throwing around a lot recently
and it is it's far easier to achieve
your material desires than it is to
renounce them and I really love that and
I spent a lot of time thinking about it
and it kind of touches on what you're
talking about there that some people may
choose either through fear of failure or
through mindfulness practice and
internal work to transcend their desires
and so I don't need the car I don't need
to be the author I am
as I am and it leads people going back
to what we said before it leads people
into this kind of apathetic no
requirement to push myself like they
would be in cuddle club they would be
that is cuddle club but the alternative
thing to realize and this is the same
this is my excuse for why a train on a
morning not want to hear your thoughts
about this if you go out and you do the
thing and tick the box you can still
transcend it
you can still transcend needing the fast
car but it is significantly easier to
transcend needing the fast car from the
driver's seat and yes you also get the
benefit that by pushing yourself forward
by that inevitably I'm not one for
objective measures of success or
quantifiable metrics of happiness and
all that sort of stuff like I'm not but
you can't deny the fact that those
things are society saying to you you are
producing something of value you are
producing something which is so
worthwhile that we are choosing to pay
you for it a [ __ ] give the money to
charity like you cannot give the you
know just give the car away give the
free clothes oh I do whatever you want
but there's no reason not to expect more
or the best that you can from yourself
and it comes back to what you said
earlier on about learning when you're
being strict enough to continue
disciplining yourself that you can
achieve more and soft enough to give
yourself a break to allow you to not go
so far that you that you then snap and
the reason that I train the reason I
train on a morning is I think there is
an inherent satisfaction in knowing that
you have completed a training session
and it resets every night when you go to
sleep so if you spend your entire day
knowing that you've got to train at 8:00
p.m. at night that's an entire day with
an open loop of anxiety saying a [ __ ]
go to dress or go to Train
so I'll go to try I'm gonna try an 8
o'clock go to Train whereas if you
finished your training session by 12
midday you're like ah rest of the day's
mine I've already got I've already got
my training out of the way because it is
a Groundhog Day that resets every single
midnight or whenever you go asleep and
you get to turn that box I I don't I am
not a good person to talk to about this
because I am psychotically disciplined
and I happen for a long
time so I am so strict with my schedule
I train at night because I don't like it
when the gym is busy
so my gym is 24 hours I would go at
11:00 midnight I go to bed at 2:00 in
the morning every night wake up at 11:00
in the morning
so if I woke up and went to the gym I
would I would resent it
for me it's relaxing to end on that and
it's also like I've been I went too
often so my buddies like 5 days a week
is plenty so I had to force myself to
take an extra rest day I know and
because I was doing 6 so but uh I I
don't know that I'm wired that way I
think if I got my work done in the mana
in the morning then I would feel antsy
that I have 14 hours to fill so I don't
know I think it also depends on how much
of output we have on how much input we
have right because I've got like three
jobs and so on and so forth so if I only
have their working out that might be a
situation where I would be like I want
to do in the first thing because then I
know if I'm not unemployed I'm not gonna
worry about hitting the phone and not
getting the call backs cuz I know I did
something for the day but since I will
have enough on my plate whether I go to
the gym or not regardless that will take
care of that part of my brain which
otherwise would be screaming it's gonna
be wasted today it's gonna be wasted
today's convoy today you're watching too
much you know you stupid videos on
YouTube yeah I wouldn't know whether
that's perhaps a little bit of me
getting easy Windsor earlier on because
I tend to work like that my morning
routine is like 10 wins by 9:00 a.m. or
10 a.m. like a ton of things so I love
gone for a walk journaled done breath
work meditated done my Spinal Rehab red
cooked and prepped my food for the day
and maybe done summer house like by 9:30
or 10:00 a.m. and that's just me
perhaps still trying to build up that
level of self confidence and kind of
belief in my own Worth to get the day
going real hard you know like kind of
self in
in a high gear type thing and get moving
so yeah it's an interest in one man how
have you been finding um training from
home and stuff like that
so I I gotta tell you I I do not take it
for granted having like a decent
audience of quality people I think I'm
very blessed to have this and I was
going absolutely crazy not having access
to gym because this is very important
for me from mental health and I was on a
cut and I was reaching I was at my peak
a few years ago I fell away because my
trainer vanished and now I was getting
back to that point and having that just
abruptly stopped it was it was really
freaking me out really badly I mean I
went to the park here at 10 o'clock you
know but you gonna do so many pull-ups
and dips and in that park whatever and I
had a fan who she's in Florida Phoebe
god bless you god bless you so much she
goes here's the key the key is in the
lockbox at my house here's the code I
called her while I was in her house I
did her dishes I you know I wanted her
plants I was glad to do it she gave me
she had a pair of 30 pound cut barbells
and a 65-pound kettlebell between that
since I'm kind of leaning at a very lean
place it's fine it's not ideal but it
certainly psychologically it's fine and
physically you know it in a great place
so having that is very very very
relaxing in that part of the brain it's
like you're wasting time or you're we
all have we have this I I don't know if
you do because you've been I mean this
has been something part of your life for
a long time I think a lot of people who
from working out as a part of their life
have this idea that your body is a
series of balloons and if you stop
working out for like a month you're
gonna be back where you started and like
years will go away now that's not how it
works at all
but emotionally that's what your brain
is telling you and there's nothing you
can do to tell it otherwise until you go
back and are like oh I dropped five
pounds potentially who cares yeah man I
I couldn't agree more one of the reasons
that I'm so happy
aleyko is a swedish company and
obviously
don't whether you know but Sweden are
essentially just going about their
business as normal yeah yeah bars and
restaurants and chair up and so you can
order kit from them so I ordered I've
got some stuff of them very fortunately
just floor lockdown started we got what
bike which is like an exercise really
sophisticated exercise bike and some
other bits and pieces one housemates a
physio in the other house made two PT so
like I you know I I miss any in a gym
I'm in a gym yeah uh and I was order
weights but they were sold out
everywhere here you know what sold out
at the moment in the UK hair clippers Oh
[ __ ] I can't get hair clippers to save
my life I am going I'm like every 1981
haircut I've been goin I headed down I
had it like the guy from the Damned
I had Duran Duran I I mean I'm like
alright I had this streak in my hair cuz
I did this tulsi gabbard look out you
put guys probably UK don't know her when
I was in theof Rubin and I thought it
was gonna grow out in one session it
does not it takes forever first you go
out and we were gonna dye it back but
then the hair come all the hair stylists
are closed by law so now it's getting
longer than it's ever been in my life I
found this I didn't know this those
round combs I guess girls know this they
straighten your hair when you comb it
out enough so Mike Harris wavy and now I
can do things with it I'm like all right
it's gonna look crazy okay I mean you
know what I would love I would
absolutely adore to see you with the top
not good man bun yeah
oh god no dude god no oh god is the
nightmare Mel nightmare bro nightmare of
all night was look so sick so yeah
here's a thing for you to listen also
you would look dude you would get so
much poon just bare poon yeah we the og
modern wisdom listeners will remember
this
so for pretty much the entire first year
that we were doing this podcast Johnny
who is Yusuf's business partner one of
the other regular co-hosts we convinced
him that a topknot was a good look and
he grew his hair for well over six
months and kept on shaving the sides and
we were like dude it's going to be
awesome and I still to this day I still
genuinely think and this is it goes back
to the weird thing right so Johnny it
has
this very oxymoronic personality makeup
he's a chartered accountant who left a
very corporate job to start his own
fitness business online which is
incredibly successful he still loves
spreadsheets he's kind of always dresses
in Hollister
Abercrombie lots of Navy nice shirt
Ralph Lauren shirts you know just kind
of a bit a little bit preferable you're
giving you URI from a hipster yes yeah I
kind of kind of preppy very very
clean-cut always well shaven but can
deadlift three hundred and twelve kilos
and it's a foul and it's a Frazee freak
power lifter he still holds the northern
deadlift record so he's unbelievable
power lifter ridiculous quality and I'm
like there's just one more thing and I
just wanted the top not the man bun to
just set him off as like a barbells
samurai and I want I want you I want I
want top not I want top not malice and
I'm more of a ninja then Samurai
yeah oh yeah that's true and it will
never ever ever my buddy who you
reminded me a lot of I'm like why am I
getting on so well with this guy Chris
I'm like oh my very very good friend
John Durant who I added his book on the
Paleo meant called a mouth paleo
manifesto you and him are very similar
in many ways and both very very white
and he had one for a long time and it
worked for him because he had this on
Capeman look but I oh my god the idea oh
my god I can't I'm just getting to know
this just disturb thinking about it
although I can pull it all I could pull
off a lot especially when you've got
that with like you you're like old
school old school jeans from like the
70s or the cords that have like got all
of the fake the pleats washed down or
whatever they call yeah it's so much
yeah maybe next year I know look Mike
come on we've we've made it we made it
all the way through we did Brian Rose we
did we did coronavirus we did your
training what you what are you doing for
shows now people want to like what you
consistently where can they go so me and
this guy Dave Smith he's a very failed
comedian he also has a show on gas
digital
my show you're welcome is on so we've
been doing cross summer episodes because
our audiences overlap a lot so by having
it like having these bro outs by having
it me on Tuesday and then him on
Thursday and then picking up having this
ongoing conversation is giving our
audiences a sense of continuity and a
sense of like okay work so that's kind
of what we've been doing now and it's
really had a very positive response so
if they want to watch me chat with one
of my buds and with you I mean if this
gives people some semblance of normalcy
or normality or happiness glad to do it
yeah man I couldn't agree more Michael
malleus on Twitter of course going here
view what have you done recently final
thing what's been your favorite tweet
that you've put out recently if the
corporate press had been as worried
about China as they've been about Russia
we've all be in a lot better place
that's a mic drop that is true
you're totally right you totally right
and that is a whole new there's a whole
new podcast now that we need to go into
is yeah yeah you see code to do that at
the very very end look Michael on thank
you so much dude it's been Knox
everybody
pleasure pleasure see you later on
[Music]